[Music]  thirty back bachelor in paradise is big  returns hi everybody I'm Lauren Zima  after a whirlwind of summer scandal  complete with a temporary shutdown  introduction and an investigation into  an on-set incident bachelor in paradise  is back in Monday nights on The  Bachelorette viewers got the first promo  for the new season Sun had almost set  summer was almost ruined  that internal ABC investigation into the  onset incident ultimately found no  wrongdoing and the bachelor in paradise  promo certainly celebrates that  addressing the scandal head-on though  bachelor in paradise season 4 kicks off  Monday night to August 14th and will  give us a two-night premiere will you be  watching let's talk about it over on  Twitter  you